Tagewache mit Kratky heute einmal ganz ohne Tagwache und auch nicht in einer Kaserne.
Einen schönen guten Abend von einem der vielen Christkindlmärkte hier in Österreich,
in dem Fall einen besonders schönen über den Dächern der Stadt Wien.
Das ist ein ganz spezieller Gruß an alle
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter und alle
Soldatinnen und Soldaten des österreichischen Heeres
inklusive einem kleinen Dank von mir persönlich für eine großartige Zusammenarbeit bisher.
Weit über 1 millionen Menschen haben bis jetzt gesehen, online,
was das Bundesheer in Österreich so drauf hat.
Das ist Ihr und euer Verdienst, dafür ein
großes Dankeschön ich freue mich schon
auf das was alles noch kommen mag.
Und es ist hier ein ganz spezieller Weihnachtsgruß an Sie alle, an euch alle,
an die, die am 24. Dezember
oder auch übers neue Jahr Dienst machen
und ganz speziell an die fast 1000 die weit entfernt von der Heimat im Ausland ihren Dienst versehen.
An euch ganz ganz herzlich frohe Weihnachten, ein friedliches neues Jahr
und ein ganz spezieller Gruß von den Herren der Garde.
Film ab.
Mit diesen Grüßen von der Garde, sage auch ich danke für eine tolle Zusammenarbeit bisher.
Ich freue mich auf ein tolles, neues, gemeinsames Jahr 2018, wünsch ihnen...
viel Soldatenglück, wer war denn das?
Wäre auch eine Schande gewesen wenn ihr nicht getroffen hättet.
Aber vor allem euch und Ihnen ein friedliches Weihnachten und einen guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr.
Alles Liebe.